mr paul mr perdue
mr peters mr portman mr reed
mr rish mr roberts mr romney
ms rosen
mr rounds mr rubio mr sanders mr sass mr
schatz mr schumer
mr scott of florida mr scott of south
carolina
mrs shaheen
mr shelby
miss cinema miss smith
miss stavenow mr sullivan mr tester
mr thune mr tillis mr toomey
mr udall mr van hollen
mr warner miss warren
mr whitehouse mr wicker
mr wyden mr young
senators voting in the affirmative
alexander barrasso blackburn
blunt bozeman brawn
burr capito collins
cramer crapo danes
enzi ernst fisher
gardner graham grassley
holly hoeven hyde smith
johnson kennedy langford
lee leffler mcconnell mcsally
purdue rish roberts
romney rounds rubio staff
scott of florida scott of south carolina
shelby
sullivan soon tillis toomey
wicker and young
mr cornyn mr cornyn uh
senators voting in the negative baldwin
bennett blumenthal booker brown
cardin carper cortes masto
duckworth durbin feinstein gillibrand
hassan hirono jones
kane klobuchar leahy
mansion marky menendez
merkley murphy murray
paul peters reed
rosen sanders
cinema smith udall van hollen
warren and wyden mr heinrich mr heinrich
no mr tester mr tester
no
mr whitehouse mr whitehouse no
[Music]
mr casey mr casey no
[Music]
miss markowski ms murkowski
mrs shaheen mr shaheen
no
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
mr king mr king no mr portman mr portman
ah
[Music]
my
so
mr coons mr coons no
thank you
mr cassidy mr cassidy ah
mr milan mr moran ah
here
no mr warner mr warner no
so
mr inhofe mr inhofe
ah
[Music]
this mr schumer mr schumer
no
[Music]
oh
mr cruz mr cruz
um
[Music]
uh
this
this
so
miss cantwell miss cantwell no
so
[Music]
so
are there any other senators wishing to
vote or change their vote
if not on this vote the yeas are 52
the nays are 47 three fifths of the
senators duly chosen and sworn not
having voted in the affirmative
the motion is not agreed to mr president
the senator for arkansas i ask unanimous
consent the senate proceed to
legislative session for a period of
morning business with senators permitted
to speak therein for up to 10 minutes
each
without objection yield the floor and i
note the absence of quorum
the clerk will call the roll mr
alexander
ah
so
[Music]
foreign
so
here we go
you
[Music]
[Music]
this
um
[Music]
so
ohio thank you mr president i ask
unanswered
without objection i i come to the floor
today first to thank senator duckworth
for leading many of us to come to the
floor this week to stand in solidarity
with all the military families around
the country and throughout our nation's
history who have sacrificed
so much in service of our country
i hope we can all join together not as
republicans and democrats but as
servants of the american people
in expressing outrage and disgust
at the comments made by the president
that were confirmed by multiple news
outlets last week
a deep reverence for the service members
including the presiding officer
who made the ultimate sacrifice for our
country a deep reverence for all service
members but
especially those who made the ultimate
sacrifice for our country
has never before been a partisan issue
in this body or in our country
these americans laid down their lives
because they love this country
they love what we stand for they
understood something
that president trump never will the idea
of service
the ethos of giving your all for
something greater
than yourself i know some of my
colleagues
will continue to bury their heads in the
sand to pretend the president couldn't
possibly have said those things
but if you don't believe it if you don't
believe it's within president trump's
character to denigrate our troops
you haven't been paying attention the
last five years president trump called
our former colleague
and our friend senator john mccain an
american war hero to every one of us
trump called him a loser he denigrated
all pows and their families when he said
i like people who weren't captured he
attacked a gold star family whose son
paid the ultimate sacrifice for our
country with anti-muslim bigotry
he repeatedly attacked and retaliated
against lieutenant colonel alexander
varvindlin
who spent his entire life serving our
country
but it's not just president trump's
words as despicable and disrespectful as
they are
it's his actions he diverted funding
from our military
bases to pay for his vanity border
project border wall
he made it easier for payday lenders to
prey on our service members by selling
them
predatory loans at exorbitant rates go
to dayton go to the wright patterson air
force base and look at the
payday rent lenders that just crop up
around our military bases
he had president handed out favors to
foreign banks like santander
that illegally repossessed service
members cars and illegally foreclosed on
their homes
while they were defending our country he
ordered the closure of the military's
newspaper
starring stars and stripes because it
refused to serve as a propaganda machine
for him
under pressure now he's saying he's
going to re
bring it back now he's failing to
protect our troops and our veterans from
this disease and his administration
used as them as guinea pigs prescribing
hydro
hydroxychloroquine tablets and unproven
coded covid treatment
he did that this spring as he was
not telling the country about the
seriousness of this disease
none of this should be partisan i know
my republican colleagues and i
disagree on a lot of things taxes and
budgets and health care policy
but i've never heard any of us disagree
on the fact
that americans who serve our country are
american heroes
whether they fought during world war one
against fascists in world war ii like my
brother did
or a defender my father did or defending
us today we owe them and their families
a debt of gratitude
those who made the ultimate sacrifice
were mothers and fathers and sons and
daughters and aunts and uncles they had
hopes
and they had dreams of devoting careers
to service
all of my colleagues have spoken to the
families of the fallen we try to empath
empathize
with the unbearable pain they go through
some of my colleagues
have been those brothers or sisters or
sons or daughters
all of our service members all of our
veterans all of their families deserve
better i asked my colleagues to join me
in joining senator duckworth and
standing in solidarity
with all american service members and
veterans and their families we'll never
forget
the debt we owe you we're humbled by
your commitment
to service
i know the absence of a quorum clerk
will call the roll
mr alexander
[Music]
so
so
now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
me
all right
now
so
so
great
this
this
uh
mr president i was uh
asked to lift the quorum call without
objection
thank you very much mr president i have
two items i'd like to
speak for a few moments on today but
first i want to
rise to say how pleased that i am that
the senate voted to confirm
judge hala jarvu to serve as the federal
judge in the u.s district circuit for
the western district of michigan
both senator peters and i supported her
returned our blue slips and we're
very pleased to support her confirmation
i think she will do an excellent job and
her
story judge jarwood's story is really an
american story
she was born in iraq and came to this
country as a young girl
she was the first person in her family
to earn her college degree
from the university of michigan and
her law degree from wayne state
university
she is the first keldean judge to serve
on the circuit court level in
oakland county michigan and she
will is now the first keldean american
to serve on the federal
bench so very very pleased
that she was confirmed today judge jarvu
greatly values the opportunity she's
been given i know
and has worked hard to extend those
opportunities
to others during her career she's active
in the michigan legal community and in
the chaldean american chamber of
commerce
and other cultural organizations
she served as a mentor and has worked to
increase the diversity of clerks in her
own
courtroom and again i'm just very
pleased
that she was overwhelmingly confirmed
by the united states senate today
mr president i rise now on
behalf of the more than 19 million
people in our nation and half a million
people in michigan
who show us every day what service and
sacrifice and love of country
is really all about these patriots
landed on beaches in normandy and the
pacific
crept through jungles in korea shed
blood
in vietnam survived attacks in iraq
and fought terrorists in afghanistan
these people are heroes they love our
nation
so much they're willing to put their
lives on the line
for our democracy our people
and our way of life that's why it is
so incredibly shocking
and infuriating to hear the president of
the united states the commander-in-chief
of our armed forces disparage our
veterans
president trump called them losers and
suckers
losers and suckers
he said he couldn't understand why
anyone would join the military because
what's in it for them
he said veterans who've lost limbs
shouldn't be in parades
why because he couldn't handle seeing
them
didn't think people would want to see
them people in michigan want to see them
and thank them
and do every day
and we all remember what he said about
our former colleague and friend
the late senator john mccain
president trump said he prefers
veterans who didn't get captured
my own dad served in the navy during
world war ii
he signed up because he believed in a
cause bigger than
himself perhaps
you know president trump doesn't
understand that my dad was a
sailor not a sucker
and about one in four people who have
served in our armed services
now live with a service-connected
disability
president trump these veterans
are leaders they aren't losers
president trump wonders what's in it for
them
well maybe he should ask them
because we all know what they would say
we all know what they would say
pride duty
honor the feeling that comes from
putting something or someone
above yourself
it's becoming increasingly clear that
these aren't feelings
that the current occupant of the oval
office
understands my dad once told me
something i've never forgotten in fact
it's influenced my whole
life as an elected official
he said that a veteran should never
stand at the back of any line
for a job for health care
for education or for the military
recognitions they earned my dad came
home
after world war ii and went to school in
the gi bill
and i don't know what would have
happened to our family if he had not had
that opportunity
and so my dad said over and over again
that a veteran should not stand at the
back
of any line
they certainly shouldn't be put at the
end of the line by
their own president it's appalling
that this even needs to be said
actually when it when i heard these
comments and heard them verified over
and over again
and and every media outlet
from right to left verifying
that in fact these were his comments
it was stunning
it was appalling and it made me very
angry
our veterans deserve a place of honor at
the front
of the line
at the front of the line and they
deserve a commander-in-chief who
respects them
who honors their service and frankly who
gets it
thank goodness we have people who see
some things
and believe in things beyond themselves
thank goodness we have people who are
willing to stand up
for all of us to keep us safe and stand
up for our values and our country
so on behalf of the people of michigan i
want to say thank you
to everyone who has served everyone who
is currently serving currently serving
our country in our armed services
we are truly grateful for your sacrifice
and service and your willingness
to stand up and support and defend
our country mr
president i yield the floor
[Music]
absence of a quorum will call the roll
mr alexander
do
hey
uh
so
foreign
consent that the quorum will be
dispensed with
without objection senator from ohio
thank you i'm on the floor today to talk
about the coronavirus pandemic and what
we can and should do here
in the united states senate and in
congress as a whole
to actually address the ongoing problems
we're not out of the woods yet
we've still got a health care crisis and
of course an economic crisis
that's a consequence of that we've done
some good bipartisan work over the past
six months in fact i think not many
people realize that
we've actually passed five or six bills
with strong bipartisan majorities
what people know about most is the
biggest one the carers act i think you
got 97 votes here
on the floor of the senate 97 to nothing
so we've in the past been able to figure
out a way to come together as
republicans and democrats
as americans to be able to address this
crisis we need to do it again
uh because we still do have a crisis we
still do have
unacceptably high levels of people
getting infected hospitalized
being in the icu fatalities and of
course our economy is not where any of
us would like to see it although it has
improved
significantly in part because of the
legislation we have passed here
i'm convinced we'd be at over 10 percent
unemployment still
if not for the legislation we passed
here instead we're beginning to come
down
8.4 last month and that's faster than
anybody thought it could
still of course unacceptably high so
more help is needed
and we can't let the upcoming election
and the politics around that keep us
from getting together and continuing to
do the work that we have to do
now we haven't been able in the last
five or six weeks to do that
instead we've been working kind of on on
opposite sides of the aisle
on our own projects today we passed a
bill
uh i'm sorry we didn't pass it we voted
on a bill that got a majority
of the united states senators supporting
it that's not how you pass something
around here you have to have
a super majority of 60 votes but a
majority of senators
in this chamber just voted for
legislation that has strong bipartisan
appeal
i would think because as we'll talk
about in a second almost every element
is supported by the democrats
republicans and most importantly by the
american people
but what we've done is we've kind of
fallen into camp so the democrats passed
a bill in the house
it's called the heroes act it's a 3.5
trillion dollar bill
and remember we've already spent about
three and a half trillion dollars making
this the largest deficit in the history
of our country
and making our debt now for the first
time since world war ii
the size of our entire economy that
concerns all of us and it should
i hope it can resolve us because our
fiscal situation
uh going forward for our kids and
grandkids is something we should be
concerned about too
anyway 3.5 trillion dollar bill
and you know it's kind of a grab bag to
be honest some of it is related to covet
19 but some of it is not
as an example there's a provision in
there that i hope will be a non-starter
that
changes our tax laws and repeals what's
called the state and local tax
deduction cap that was put in place just
recently this gives a huge break to
wealthy americans back 40 percent of
this benefit according to the joint
committee on taxation
goes to the top one percent of wage
earners
now what does that have to do with the
coronavirus it'll help millionaires on
both coasts a lot
but it really does not affect the crisis
that we're in
they also want to use this 3.5 trillion
dollar package as a way to make
changes in our immigration policy now
that's pretty controversial stuff as it
stands
and that's going to make of course that
bill hard to pass because immigration
policy
people have strong views on but it has
no place in a covet 19 bill
one that also concerns those of us who
are concerned about the election coming
up
is it puts federal mandates in place on
the states
that are unprecedented with regard to
their election system
that's something we've always left to
the province of the states but instead
it puts mandates in place
on the electoral system that's not again
something that is going to help us in
terms of the coronavirus so
my hope is that those house democrats
who passed that bill
can now see what we've passed over here
this is a very targeted bill that
focuses on the
coronavirus it is less than 500 billion
dollars which used to be a lot of money
around here
but uh as compared to the 3.5 trillion
dollars so it's obviously a lot less
money
but it's also more targeted more focused
and again i think so much of it
is policy that can be supported on both
sides of the aisle and will really help
to be able to continue the efforts we've
started here to help address the health
care crisis
but also help with regard to the weak
economic performance as a result
of people being isolated from the
economy i heard someone this week say
we've got a k
recovery uh what does that mean well you
think of the letter k
a lot of people say you want to have a v
recovery where you go down steeply to a
recession then you come back up just as
steeply that's where i think a lot of
america is in other words
a lot of families a lot of businesses
have seen pretty rapid recovery here in
the past few months
but there are others who have not so the
first the top part of the k
is true for a lot of people and a lot of
businesses
think of the businesses that provide
food the
grocery stores the businesses that are
involved in construction
uh businesses like home depot or lowe's
that provide
building products doing well at the top
of the day they're in the v
but there are others that are in the
bottom that would include
uh travel and hospitality it would
certainly include the airlines
bus companies they're having a tough
time
many of our smaller businesses retail
certainly our bars and
movie theaters and bowling alleys
they're having a tough time so they're
at the bottom end of that so
this is an uneven recovery and we have
to acknowledge that and therefore
to my colleagues on my side of the aisle
who might say you know we've done enough
the recovery's on
everything's good unfortunately that's
not true
i wish it were i wish we had turned the
corner
on the economy and also begun to turn
the corner on the virus
we can't say that yet we've made
progress
no question about it i think we're on
the right track but we have a k-shaped
recovery i believe
by the way same with individuals think
about it if you own your own home
the value of your home has probably gone
up you're probably in pretty good shape
look if you're trying to sell your home
right now it's a good time to sell i
guess
if you're invested in the stock market
which a lot of people who own their own
homes are
it's been darn good and the market
increase
has been substantial i was on a program
this morning where they were talking
about how the nasdaq is back up again
the tech stocks and if you're in the
tech
world you're doing great but let's say
you don't own your own home let's say
you're a renter
your rent's likely to start going up if
it hasn't already let's say you're not
invested in the market so you're not
taking advantage of that and yet
your job's at risk may be gone
so again k-shaped isn't it some people
doing quite well
others are still having a rough time and
need help
to be able to deal with the issue of the
coronavirus
and the economic fallout from that
by the way this k-shape recovery i
believe has increased
inequality in terms of our income in
this country
and income inequality was something we
were making progress on
in february we had the 19th straight
month
of wages increasing over 3 percent in
this country just in february not long
ago
by the way most of that increase was
among lower and middle income workers
now that was positive that was where we
wanted to head as a country that's why
so many of us push for tax reform and
regulatory relief thinking that would
get this economy moving and help those
workers who are in the lower and middle
income bracket the most and guess what
it did but that's changed now so
we have to here in congress in my view
continue to help
continue to do things that will help on
the health care crisis
and with regard to the underlying
economic situation that's affected by it
one thing that
i think was very positive
about today is that we were able to pass
legislation
that has many many bipartisan elements
to it
i think the vote we just had again where
a majority of senators in this chamber
voted for a targeted covet 19 approach
i think this gives us a chance to reset
a chance to get back to the bargaining
table a chance to say okay
now the republicans have put forward a
proposal
that has a lot of very reasonable
provisions in it the presiding officer
here today
was part of that he put in provisions uh
into the bill that has to do with our
schools
widely popular there's other provisions
in there that
that i think there's very little
disagreement on let me highlight
a few of them one is on the health care
response particularly on our testing
capacity
republicans and democrats alike know
that testing is critical
we need it in ohio we're looking for
more funding for testing because we know
that's how you stop the spread of this
disease testing contact tracing
getting to these hot spots and trying to
contain it
that way people will feel more
comfortable by the way returning to work
returning to shop
returning to school so this is something
that
is in this legislation 16 billion
dollars alone for testing
the legislation that was voted on this
afternoon in this chamber
voted positively by a majority of the
senators
just last week in ohio i visited the
health collaborative which is a
multi-agency
coalition approach to dealing with covet
19.
it includes hospitals county
commissioners health commissioners
even nursing homes they're utilizing the
19 million dollars they've received
through the cares act
to fund and design and execute a testing
strategy
for people in the southwest ohio area
i am really pleased to see them take the
funding and using it in this way because
now more and more people are getting the
opportunity to be tested
and by the way they're doing it on a no
needs
basis there's there's there's no need to
pay for
this testing with your insurance if you
don't have it everybody is welcome to
get a test
these kinds of initiatives are a big
help and i'm glad that in this
legislation we
voted on this afternoon we added another
45 billion dollars in total to hhs to go
for
testing vaccine development to get this
vaccine
is possible distribution of the vaccine
helping on the
antiviral medications this shark tank
concept that again the presiding officer
and others have been involved with is
brilliant because
it sort of tells the private sector look
we're going to provide you the basic
funding to go out there and compete
to come up with a safe way to develop a
a vaccine or an antiviral therapy
and that's encouraged competition and in
unprecedented speed
we are developing these alternatives
thank goodness
and we need them hopefully by the end of
this year we will have them
second i think we agree that congress
should double down on any coveted 19
policies in previous legislations
that have worked well and one of course
is what's called the paycheck protection
program
that's in this legislation voted on
today too back on august 8th it ended
so if you're a small business out there
and you have not already taken advantage
of the ppp
program that many of your peers have and
you've seen them be able to keep their
doors open because of it
you're out of luck right now because the
program is not accepting new applicants
so we need to extend that program i
think everybody agrees with that
i don't know a senator in this chamber
that doesn't have an experience back
home
of a small business saying i couldn't
have stayed open without this
i visited three or four businesses just
in the past few weeks in ohio
all of them had the same story different
timing
you know different businesses some in
construction some in the restaurant
business
some in manufacturing but what they all
tell me is
they needed that influx badly it
provided them a low interest loan one
percent that converted into a grant
effectively because the loan was
forgiven if they used it for their
salaries
or for their utilities or for their
mortgage or rent
they would have had to close their doors
and let a lot of people go
they were able to hang on and for some
of these businesses like the
manufacturer i visited
thank goodness because they would let go
30 of their workforce
they didn't have to do that they kept
everybody on now they're going great
guns they're looking for people
by the way they're having a tough time
hiring people
they're looking for people and that's a
good sign that
you have businesses out there trying to
pull people into the workforce
so that's in this legislation my hope is
that
we're going to see republicans and
democrats agree on this
i think they do agree reinstating the
ppp for the foreseeable future so that
more small businesses can take advantage
of the smart loan program is a smart
thing to do
and it is more targeted and it does
require you show a loss of revenue
that's okay that's good we want this to
be targeted and focused we don't want to
waste money
third the bill reflects that members on
both sides of the aisle
recognize that congress should give
additional support to our schools
i mentioned this earlier but 105 billion
dollars in this bill goes to
education about 70 billion to k-12
our primary and secondary schools and
high schools and and
that's needed right now you know we're
trying to reopen around the country and
many of these schools are telling me rob
i got additional costs i've got these
plexiglas shields i've got to put up
i've got to reconfigure the classroom
i've got to hire more teachers because i
want smaller classrooms
so if someone gets sick they'll be
infecting a smaller group
there's funding that's needed for remote
learning
so this is good for us to provide
funding for these schools because that
will enable them
to reopen and reopen safely and stay
open that's in this legislation
and by the way there's also money in
here for colleges and universities think
about 30 billion for that
again same thing i'm hearing back home
from our colleges and universities
some of which are having a tough time
staying open they do need more help more
testing more ppe
personal protective gear so this is
important too and
again that's all in this legislation
interestingly i mentioned the heroes act
earlier 3.5 trillion dollar bill that
the house
democrats passed not too long ago is
kind of their alternative
that had funding for schools also but
guess what
this bill that was passed well not
passed but voted on by a majority of
senators today in the united states
senate
actually has slightly more money than
the heroes act has
for education what's the big issue here
why can't we get together and figure
this out
so there's so many opportunities here
finally i would just say that one thing
that this bill does and one reason it's
called a targeted bill
is it repurposes funding that we have
already appropriated
here in the first four or five bills but
that has not been used
is not likely to be needed so isn't that
smart
i mean as taxpayers don't you want to be
sure that we're not just throwing money
at this problem that's not needed
and the treasury department in
particular has been helpful in working
with us saying they got
a bunch of money that they could use for
a loan program they haven't
had much take up on because frankly the
commercial
lending is going pretty well right now
people are able to get money from their
banks they don't need to come to
treasury or to the fed
as much as we thought they might so
there's money left over we're talking
hundreds of billions of dollars
so that should certainly be used to
offset the cost of any new program
i think that's just a common sense idea
i can't imagine anybody in this chamber
if they think through this would be
against us repurposing the funds we've
already appropriated toward new uses
that are more targeted
that's in this legislation too i think
those things
all have bipartisan appeal and
it seems to me again this is a reset
because let's face it the democrats have
been saying over the past several weeks
well fine we've got our bill we passed
the heroes act what have you guys
put out showing that at least the
majority of the senate
and pretty much every republican can
support now we've done that
so we have our stake in the ground they
have their stake in the ground
a lot of overlap i just talked about
four areas where there's considerable
overlap
but there's many others as well we
should be able to figure this out on
behalf of the american people yeah we
have a campaign
ongoing for president or senators
for members of congress we've got to
look out for the interests
of the american people here we can do
both we can campaign and also
be working on our legislation that is
absolutely needed right now for the
health care and
economic future for our country by the
way only
about a third of the senate is up for
re-election so for two-thirds of us
we don't even have the election to worry
about and yet it seems like this place
has become way too political too quickly
so let's focus on taking this bill that
was voted on today a majority of
senators supported it
and figuring out ways to work with
democrats to come up with
a new approach that enables us to
continue the effort
to help with regard to this k-shaped
recovery to help with regard to the
ongoing
healthcare crisis that we're facing i
want to mention if i could
three or four other things i'd love to
see in the final bill that
did not make it in the so-called
targeted bill
and i understand why they didn't in part
because we weren't looking to put a lot
of tax provisions in there because it's
not a
tax vehicle but i do think there's other
things that have broad
bipartisan support that we ought to
include
first i think we would all agree it's
important that the taxpayer-funded
research that's supported by this
legislation research into anti-viral
medications research into vaccines
is protected from other countries in
particular china
coming in to our country and taking that
research
this is taxpayer-funded research and we
know
from what the fbi has told us what the
department of justice has told us that
this is currently a risk
it is currently a risk with that in mind
we need to include legislation that
safeguards our american innovation
this was actually in the legislation
that was introduced by senator mcconnell
a few weeks ago called the heels
legislation
and the legislation that i'm talking
about is called the safeguarding
american innovation act it
stops this kind of theft of research and
innovation
at our research institutions our
colleges our universities
there's that's one where republicans and
democrats have come together it's a
bipartisan bill
it's a result of a committee process
it's a result of a
investigation that took over a year it's
a result of a lot of hearings and a lot
of work and it's
solid legislation to encourage us to
be able to protect the research that
we're doing including on the coronavirus
second
there's been for a while now a
bipartisan consensus that a smart
coronavirus response
should include tax incentives to help
our economy
to be able to not just open and reopen
but do so safely
and effectively small business owners
i've spoken to during this pandemic
especially in recent weeks
have told me they're eager to be open
but they want to do it in a safe manner
and we want them to do it in a safe
manner let's provide some incentives for
that
one example of how that process can be
helped along is an expanded tax credit
for new hiring called the work
opportunity tax credit
it's already out there it's legislation
that passed years ago and
it helps let's say veterans uh returning
citizens who are
looking for a second chance it gives
them the chance to get a job because the
employer gets a tax credit for a while
and then
almost always that person ends up
getting a job let's include
covet 19 unemployed in that people
who've lost their job because of cobit
19.
that makes all the sense in the world to
get people back to work
there's also something that's in law now
based on the cares legislation called
the employee
retention tax credit this i think is
very important
companies that couldn't access the ppp
because they didn't qualify
or didn't want to i have access to this
program kind of as an alternative
and it gives companies a tax credit
against their payroll taxes the
employer-side payroll taxes
if they keep people on or bring people
on again this makes all the sense in the
world right now to encourage more
hiring to ensure we can get this economy
moving again
and do so safely speaking of safely i've
also introduced a new tax credit
that was part of the heels legislation
that was introduced a few weeks ago
it's called the healthy workplaces tax
credit which helps businesses pay for
this protective equipment
like the plexiglas shields like the ppe
that they now need
which is expensive just the gowns and
the masks
and the gloves those expenses add up
particularly for businesses they're
having a tough time
because of the weakening economy out
there
these credits will help not just to
reopen again but to reopen
safely and i think getting these kinds
of tax credits into the coronavirus
legislation
would be very smart and again this
should be bipartisan efforts
third while i'm pleased we're
revitalizing the successful ppp program
i think there are steps to improve it
that we ought to take up in whatever our
final package is
for example one oversight in the
original ppp legislation
is that people who have been convicted
of a felony going back five years are
not able to accept the ppp loan
so one day i get a call from
a guy back home and troy parker's name
troy said
i can't get a ppp loan i am a
guy who you know had a financial issue
financial fraud issue i had a felony
conviction
i got out of incarceration and i started
my own business
i took my second chance he said i did
everything that you are always talking
about portman which is
we want to encourage people to take that
second chance we want to give them the
opportunity
to get the training to be able to do
that and then he went out and hired a
bunch of other second chance
folks he started the cleaning business
and it's quite successful
but obviously with coronavirus a lot of
the offices he cleaned and others said
we
we can't have you come in he lost his
businesses
he was about to shut his doors he
couldn't get a ppp loan why because
within the last five years he'd had a
felony conviction well
that's not what we should be doing here
we shouldn't be penalizing people who've
turned their lives around and done again
all the right things
and hiring other second chance
individuals we should be helping them to
stay on their feet and to continue to do
what they're doing for themselves the
community their workforce
so we worked with the treasury
department and to their credit
we got them to put forward a temporary
solution which was a change in the rule
so that troy could get his ppp loan and
others like him around the country
we now need to make that permanent so
that's an example of something we should
do
totally bipartisan and i worked with
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle on this issue and i'll continue to
because this is one where again
republicans democrats alike
as americans would want this to be part
of the legislation
fourth while i'm glad this bill reflects
the bipartisan support for educational
funding
i had hoped it would also reflect that
republicans and democrats
alike have come out for additional
support and flexibility
for state and local governments now
ohio's particularly hard hit here
because our
cities in ohio unlike your city wherever
you are in america probably
can use income taxes as a revenue source
i think 90 percent of cities can't do
that but in ohio we can
and we do and obviously income taxes
went down with this coronavirus and the
economy uh falling short so they
suddenly find themselves with
less revenue coming in and then
additional expenses fire police ems
coronavirus expenses for public health
so it's been tough for a lot of our
cities in ohio
and so i've been pushing for not just
more funding
on a targeted basis showing need but
also more flexibility
[Music]
what
[Music]
uh
one two three four five
six seven eight
good
so
yes
thank you
you